Twenty-five years after
roaring into theaters,
"The Lion King" is back,
this time with a more realistic look.
But is the remake really
more true-to-nature
than the original?
To be fair to Disney,
they did fix some mistakes
from the original version.
Take Rafiki.
In one scene in the 1994 film,
he and Simba argue about
which one of them is a baboon.
It means you're a baboon, and I'm not.
NARRATOR: Clearly,
Simba is not a baboon...
but neither is Rafiki.
He's a different kind of
monkey altogether, a mandrill.
And what's more, Rafiki has a long tail,
yet in real life, mandrills
are nearly tailless.
Luckily, Disney fixes this
problem in the remake,
so now Rafiki looks like the
mandrill he's meant to be.
But unfortunately,
Disney didn't get the
mandrills' behavior quite right.
See how they're swinging
through the trees?
Yeah.
Mandrills don't really do that.
They spend most of their
time on the ground,
and when they do take to the trees,
they walk across the
branches on all fours.
This swinging behavior
is actually more similar
to how a gibbon moves.
But enough about mandrills.
What about the lions of "The Lion King"?
Well, there are a few problems there, too.
Take the iconic lion roar.
Sounds majestic, right?
Just like the famous MGM roar.
Here's the issue.
A lion's roar doesn't sound like that.
This is a roar.
It's not quite as majestic as
what you hear in the movie,
but that sound can still travel
up to 8 kilometers away.
Some of the lions' behavior is also off...
and that's not including
talking with ghosts.
MUFASA: Remember.
NARRATOR: Watch how Simba
scampers off with his dad.
It's a touching scene, but in real life,
Sarabi would never let
Simba out of her sight.
While lion cubs do play
with their fathers,
their mothers are extremely protective.
And you can't blame them because
if a new male comes to town
and takes over the pride,
he'll try to kill their young cubs.
Sound familiar?
That's right.
Scar's scheme to usurp Mufasa
was in line with normal lion behavior,
except his methods were
rather unconventional
because lions and hyenas
don't work together.
Ever.
In fact, they're major
competitors for food in the wild.
So it's hard to believe that a lion
could convince a hoard of
hyenas to do his dirty work,
even with a catchy villain song.
♪ Be prepared ♪